[Musique]
depuis deux ans dans cet hôtel du 13e
arrondissement vive des familles prises
en charge par le Samu social avec la
baisse de fréquentation liée à la crise
sanitaire des chambres ont été mis à
leur disposition mais maintenant ils
doivent quitter les lieux
tu as pris froid tu as dormi dehors
c'est ces jours-ci avec tes enfants
aussi il y a déjà plusieurs semaines à
Minata et ses trois enfants du quitter
la chambre qu'ils occupaient pendant
qu'ils sont à l'école elle vient devant
l'hôtel chercher de l'aide auprès du
comité de soutien qui s'est formé contre
leurs expulsions
c'est difficile
les hôtels veulent rouvrir au touristes
et à Paris ce sont 2500 personnes qui
doivent laisser leur place où est-ce que
tu as eu ton premier
ton premier hébergement en quittant ici
Paris
l'hébergement est tellement insalubre
caminata préfère encore la rue
c'est pas propre en fait il y a les
cafards il y a l'épine
[Applaudissements]
je suis trop stress
é
j'ai fait déjà
[Musique]
deux semaines de
Marie-Josée militante associatif tente
de rappeler le numéro d'urgence pour lui
trouver une solution j'ai une mère qui
se dit que voilà
c'est
l'inadmissible est imposée à ses enfants
vous n'avez pas vous n'avez rien et vous
n'avez rien c'est pas possible de
trouver quelque chose de plus temporaire
pour quelques jours
disons Paris Aminata fini par quitter
les lieux sans avoir décidé où elle est
ses enfants passeront la nuit ce soir
des familles récemment expulsées d'un
autre hôtel du 13e arrondissement ont
été relogés ici l'hôtel Excelmans
c'était pourtant promis à la démolition
est fermée depuis plusieurs mois quand
elles y sont arrivés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non on peut pas dormir là
j'ai acheté tout sauf de produits javel
tout il y a plein de souris et cafards
ici c'est trop
j'étais obligé d'acheter les sacs pour
mettre tout notre affaire dedans pour
déposer là parce que il a souri qui a
même bouffé les affaires de mes enfants
on a fait deux valises pour mes affaires
de les enfants dedans pour mettre dans
le placard dans la deuxième chambre où
les deux enfants et le couple se tassent
c'est à peine mieux
et puis les enfants n'ont pas d'espace
il y a des punaises dans le tapis
et la moquette ça pue
un autre étage même constat chez Nawa
Ibrahima parent de deux petites filles
une situation d'autant plus
insupportable que le couple a des
revenus
j'ai fait le demande du DALO le 31 5h de
le DALO c'était le 35 5 de 2022 au
dossier est n'est pas encore arrivé en
commission donc je sais pas il y a un
bon salaire
un salaire qui va mais c'est pas trop
mais un salaire qui va jusqu'à 1500
euros je pense que je peux juste avoir
un logement pour les enfants le DALO
droit au logement opposable est un
dispositif juridique qui permet de faire
valoir son droit un logement social 20 à
25% des personnes qui ont recours à
l'hébergement d'urgence ils sont en
réalité éligibles
dans les locaux de Caritas l'association
DALO anime une permanence pour
accompagner sans abri et mal logé dans
leur démarche donc actuellement déjà
vous êtes dans quelle situation il y a
marqué des projets de logement un petit
peu de partout
ça s'appelle son domicile fixe dépourvu
de logement d'accord vous avez une
demande de logement social depuis
combien de temps déposer ça a dépassé
après 2016 et 2018 vous avez deux
critères et en attente d'un logement
social
d'allongement social depuis un délai
anormalement long et l'urgence est
avérée la réalité qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment de logements sociaux et
donc en attendant d'être d'avoir un
logement les personnes en dehors d'être
à la rue comme seules situations de
demander à être hébergé mise à l'abri
mais de la même manière qu'il n'y a pas
assez de logement il y a pas assez de
place d'hébergement et ceux qui ont
besoin d'un hébergement parce qu'ils
sont totalement à la rue et qui n'ont
pas droit pour X raisons un logement
tout de suite ou qui sont pas encore
éligibles au logement social
non pas de place et se retrouve toujours
dehors et vous nous tenez au courant
pour pour la suite quand vous avez la
réponse l'objectif du recours être
reconnu prioritaire et voir son dossier
placé en haut de la pile mais même dans
ce cas là les délais sont longs
aujourd'hui plus de 85 000 personnes
dont le dossier a été accepté attendent
toujours d'être relogé